against kiri with the white pieces and
here we go and here we go it's not some
georgia's day anymore but it's the
english opening instead
and uh magnus carlsen pushing his
seaporn forward um he's been kind of
just experimenting with a whole variety
of openings so far in the oslo esports
cup and here we go
white bringing a night out actually
they've had this before against each
other in the past giri usually here
pushing a pawn in the center and which
pawn is it going to be it looks like
he's about to head for the symmetrical
english it looks like he was about to
push the black sea pawn forward but
changing his mind on each giri so maybe
not having expected this opening for
magnus carlsen yet she goes for the move
i was expecting
this one geary has played many times
before and magnus
now going for the four nights variation
of the english and a set of trades
it's called the reverse dragon the
system because it's like a dragon
sicilian but we're
with reverse colors white having an
extra move
and uh still very well known stuff from
both players and niche about to push the
black h-pawn forward
and uh yeah a theoretical battle between
them who's done the better homework
that's the big question
simon do you have any experience here
you have released a chessboard course on
the english opening yeah i mean um i
played these positions
uh when i was young as well the english
opening for most of my life um and
this is actually one of the reasons i
gave up the english this variation from
the white side i i i didn't like giving
away the space advantage when i had the
white pieces and you can sort of see
that black already has a pawn uh farther
further advanced than white and that
just wasn't something i i enjoyed doing
so again even if the opening which is
perfectly playable
and maybe even better for white is is
you know computer says it you've got to
go for what you like playing uh the kind
of positions you enjoy and i just didn't
like playing these positions um
both of them very well prepared i mean
uh i think they've drawn this kind of
thing lots of times before so i would
be heading that way if i was going to
predict a result um maybe ivanka you've
got yeah i've got some stats so up until
this bishop move that magnus just played
the two were actually repeating a game
that they had played against each other
in 2019 in the gasham memorial um
after this uh bishop move
well er
magnus has never played this but a niche
has definitely faced it
twice once against maxine bachelor graf
last year in zagreb and
also in 2020 against wang hao and well
he has mixed memories because he lost
the game to maxim bachelor graph but he
did defeat wang hao with the black
pieces in this particular position
okay interesting so anish clearly
having studied this position before
magnus must have done right if he's
raced into this position he must have
studied anish's previous games that's
what the top players do we talk about
training camps opening preparation half
of it is just looking at your opponent's
games looking for weaknesses looking for
positions you think they weren't
comfortable that they didn't understand
well and okay after just a little bit of
thought anish centralizes his rook
very sensible stuff so far black's queen
in the middle of the board normally
feeling a bit uncomfortable here
especially because white's light squared
bishop is on the same diagonal but any
time white's knight jumps out the way
attacking the black queen using that
white light squared bishop she'll just
retreat and no real harm done
and it comes as no surprise that uh this
is the exact same approach that he
employed against wang hao when he won he
won yeah you tend to repeat those uh
good memories yeah i messed with a
winning recipe right yeah it's probably
a kind of a battle of preparations isn't
it because you would have thought
that top players will realize this
magnus you would have thought i don't
know if it's right or not would know
about this game that anish has had
against wang
and he would have some improvement
somewhere but that's not always the case
and
he is uh obviously a bit under the
weather so he might not have had a
chance to you know
but know about that game so it's very
interesting these uh preparational
battles basically for
you know this kind of account and i was
just going to say you know
it's chess is different than before
because before the players didn't play
that much
and you could kind of memorize the few
hundred games that they had played now
the players are playing thousands of
games online and
they are so flexible with their opening
repertoires you know and we saw magnus
open up with this ridiculous 1f3 and uh
erwin lamy who's anish's second actually
said oh no he has to now prepare a
little bit against that just in case so
i mean
there's so much information out there so
it's impossible just to we were thinking
earlier on
i was about to get myself in a lot of
trouble
what are you going to do simon
well we were sitting on the chairs um i
was sitting on anisha's chair ivanka was
sitting on magnus's chair just for a
little photo shoot and um this is
probably about i don't know 10 minutes
before the game started yeah and we
thought what if we move the pawns we're
free
on anisha's board and also do the same
likewise for magnus's border just the
mirror and
that sounds like i i've had many
teachers who have done that same room
simon
i recognize that why am i not surprised
i do recognize that home definitely yes
yes
i kind of would have liked it though it
would be interesting to see would they
be angry would they smile and laugh and
then we thought maybe expand the whole
idea and do the whole room yeah yeah
yeah and you know just see whether
anything collective laugh and like
exactly i mean there's a famous story i
think i've mentioned before but the
british championships i think it was
british one year there was a disgruntled
chess player he'd lost a couple of games
he had some argument with the arbiter
this is going back a lot of years and he
snuck into the tournament hall in the
middle of the night with a pack of super
glue and he super glued all the kings
down to the squares
might be a myth but this is what i heard
and i'm sure i'm sure it happened
somewhere probably not the british
championships and
all the players went to castle at a
certain point and they tried to lift
their kings up and all the ball came up
as well it's like someone super glued
the king to the thing and he was looking
through the window got his revenge and
then oh yeah what's it you simon when
you say it with someone else
no
yeah
well would it be even possible though to
what how would you do it if you made the
one f3 move on the board it's just
pretty much pre-moved okay for everyone
have them all and uh that'd be brilliant
they actually sit down their first movie
exactly first we need to go
it comes out for both everyone and it
would be like pandemonium yeah yeah and
panicking and like no no no i didn't
make it
yeah probably a good thing we didn't do
that actually in hindsight
i think and the arbiters would probably
look at us and go
you know
yeah
we should mention that our on-site
arbiters have very very nice people but
we wouldn't have been their favorites if
we'd done that
no definitely all right
the arbiter is keeping an eye on all the
action happening inside the oslo esports
arena making sure everything is in order
that the players are happy
and
that they get to play their music anish
geary i know he's playing some sort of
dutch top something list oh interesting
yeah and well it's a lot of fun and
excitement in the arena and everyone at
home we love it when you join in the
action and we also really like it when
you send us your selfies and uh to start
everyone off we have uh hey dm jawa
who says that watching chess can be
anywhere even at the beach this sunday
cannot get better oh lucky lucky you
hedy and keep on enjoying the show and
uh anish retweeting his queen gabrielle
cuello says uh watching all these chess
legends playing and commentating thank
you very much for the nicer compliment
with my young total legend very sweet
picture
future chess player yeah or a current
chess player probably yeah definitely
you're current these days isn't it
absolutely champion i mean they just
started so young yeah
but uh
talking about questions there's also a
question for you kaya
coach casey asks what is your favorite
opening
didn't i have a favorite
opening i don't remember what it was
anymore i should touch the dutch english
english what was it i don't know this
sicilian idol thank you yes i was going
to say that
i uh i'm not at that level actually even
if i follow chess now every day which
porn do you pick up do you pick kingston
oh yeah usually maybe the king's pawn
no no
do you just like switch
yeah
it's always one of the two points i
never get
do anything crazy stuff with the knights
or anything it's one of those two
central pawns
i will push no pawn to f3
no pawn to f3 never ever ever no because
i would fall into the false mate that's
my problem
yeah no i'm not at that level uh you
yeah might surprise you even because i
do listen to the best chess players
every day talk about chess
but i'm having a hard time memorizing
those openings super hard chessable
gotta get on chat i know yes
that's why it's there yeah all right and
check out your uh you have a couple
courses on chessboard right simon i got
got a fair few yeah
the last one that came out was um the
life and times of mikhail tao so it's
actually
him he wrote this one and he was one of
their most interesting chess players my
favorite chess player of all time yeah
um but i i done 15 hours of videos on
this game so yeah yeah there's a lot of
videos and
he was a great player but he's also very
interesting character he had you know
very funny guy and had some great
stories so we try to talk a bit about
that and what he did to become so great
so yeah but as many courses on chess
ball something for everyone really
absolutely yep no doubt about it we do
have a few moves on the board is it
still
um it's the car before the storm yeah
okay bass players just kind of marking
out their territory we haven't talked so
much about the last few moves because
both players were just kind of improving
their pieces slowly if you look at
white's army here it's all kind of
camped out on the first three ranks
uh not really
kind of pushing forward yet not really
initiating that kind of action between
the two uh two sets of forces black
meanwhile spent a lot of moves with the
queen that's why we normally say don't
bring your queen out too early because
black had to use a couple moves to
retreat her to a safe square just to
make sure she wouldn't get
hit by a set of bishops maybe hit by
some pawns and now magnus with this last
pawn push just getting ready to expand
and push white's pawns forward on this
left flank we would call that a minority
attack if white pawns the two pawns
there the amd pawns do start to push
forward there are targets as well
black's knight not ideally placed looks
like it's controlling the center but
maybe a white pawn can kick it away
later and the black dark square bishop
again looks good but could be a target
uh meanwhile anishigiri needs to develop
his light squad bishop to a good square
maybe bring that rook out from the from
the corner lots of choice for him this
pawn structure comes from the sicilian
defense and it's really hard to handle
for both sides white has an extra
central pawn two versus one but black
has very active pieces i have a question
for you david because white has kind of
signaled his intention just like you say
he's going to expand on the left side
time to prevent it or
focus
on development i know that if magnus
carlsen were black here he wouldn't
hesitate right he would pick up black's
a pawn and push it two squares because
he loves gaining space on on all sides
of the board every flank
um i would probably do the same
but maybe anish is looking for something
a bit more direct
black for example does have the option
of planting the knight into the center
of the board offering up some trades
there
usually that's quite a
kind of safe approach for black if you
can go for it but
anish i think he's debating yeah whether
to pick up black's a pawn push it two
squares gain space maybe bring out the
black light square bishop or plant the
black knight in the middle i think a
very normal idea here is to put that
light squared bishop on where it points
at the knight
because
one thing that often happens the black
knight certainly wants to come into the
center of the board
white will probably have to take that
night off and black will take with the
pawn i don't know if we can show that
and you get this kind of pawn structure
right where now black has an open file
and you've got to try to utilize that
open file and bringing a bishop out
where it's kind of pointing at that
weakness is is also a good idea and i
think this is a strategy actually that
in the sicilian you see this against the
dragon which is a reverse version of
this
um the tempo down which david mentioned
and it was called the carport variation
this is something that i think karpov
played quite often um and i know that
because my friend adam hunt beat me with
this idea once and uh he told me it was
the carpool variation but he could have
been fibbing
he just beat me and pretended he was car
pop and i was like yeah i believe you
but similar kind of thing happening
anyway david here
in the game so basically the same uh
pawn structure we just uh demonstrated
right there but instead of taking with
his bishop white traded the knights off
so now it's purely bishops on so no more
tricky night hops no more uh night forks
later to worry about but it's all about
the diagonals and the white bishops do
look very good on these two diagonals
right now the black queen was attacked
certainly she's found a safe square for
her in the middle of the board and she's
pretty safe here right now because white
really doesn't want to push pawns
forward to attack the queen and this
would just give away weak squares and uh
okay interesting position it's just
about whether white can utilize his
bishops right now black has got
everything defended and as simon
mentioned there is a bit of a backward
pawn this is maybe a long-term target
for black because any time it pushes
forward it's just going to get captured
by the black pawn
so yeah it's a bit of a standoff right
now
personally i think magnus will be pretty
happy i was about to say that and then i
saw him on the webcam but
normally magnus would be pretty happy
with this type of position because it's
quite stabilized there's not too much
drama going on the white king very very
safe and magnus at some point will start
pushing this pawn forward maybe moving
his bishop out the way and then pushing
the other pawn as well but uh aneesh
he for sure has analyzed this type of
pawn structure as simon mentioned from a
different opening maybe uh anish after
all did do a chessable course on the
sicilian dragon himself
and here he's basically playing that
opening just with colors reversed
so very tense position still a lot of
action yet to come and okay magnus
starts by choosing to offer a trade of
bishops if you can get rid of this dart
squad bishop which was actually blocked
in then maybe the black pawns will
become a bit weak for example if we see
everything fly off the board lots of
exchanges happen now white is the one
with the targets white's rooks get very
very active
okay and no trades yet
and he says you can do it but on my
terms he pushes forward and magnus doing
the same the minority attacks is coming
these two are going to undermine black's
three pawns over here
so very tense middle game it certainly
is tense and uh not easy for anish i
mean at first i was quite optimistic
about black's position i kind of saw
well the queen is nicely centralized but
uh in this next
you know space a few moves
magnus is suddenly done doing his
favorite thing and uh when those
pawns start rolling
there's gonna be problems especially
along that long diagonal for the light
squared bishop
yeah it seems seems fairly typical this
this kind of position for the middle
game uh that you get here i mean i
suppose the only odd thing for my eyes
is where white's bishop is you know that
that dark square bishop but i agree with
you vancouver i mean that white has this
easy plan the minority attack of opening
up the light square bishop just trying
to win a pawn on the queen side and i
think this is why anish has played the
last move he wants to try and move that
bishop he's positioned into the center
to get rid of white's very strong
bishop in front of his king
yeah nice move by magnus though because
uh anish wanted to trade off the light
square bishops and magnus is saying
oh
very sneaky movie very sneaky because he
can go e4 right yeah bishop that's
that's a very good move otherwise i
think yeah we have to be happy here we
have to show this on the board magnus
looking very happy with himself after
this last move
is that one of those satisfying moves to
make basically yes and we've got to show
why he's so happy with himself magnus
there because this is black's plan after
all revealed by black's last move
putting the bishop on the square as you
guys mentioned white's like square
bishop is one of the key pieces both
from a defensive point of view but also
long term on this diagonal so if black
can trade these pieces off black is
doing very very well but magnus now
he'll push his pawn two squares forward
and on passant is possible it's legal
but it would be a big blunder here so
normally this pawn push would be met by
black capturing as if the pawn moved
just one square but now suddenly loose
pieces drop off and the black queen
would fall on this diagonal so um a
really interesting move there from
magnus do you think they should make on
pass on as a rule you have to capture it
yeah just just to mix up a little bit of
chess so if one person is available you
have to play it that could be you know
because they had this you know idea of
trying to sort of make chess a little
bit different and that'd be quite a
subtle way of making chess a little bit
different i think that means magnus
would win by force if uh if it were this
position if that's right could push his
pawn forward yeah yeah finish had to
take it as if it moved one square yeah
and he should lose his queen by four so
that's it that's the threat e4 is
actually a threat to win the queen a
winning threat so be if chess is not
difficult enough
yeah make it a bit more difficult shall
we yeah
i like the fact there are no forced
moves
yeah like that in chess it's like a fair
enough yeah chess is like warfare after
all and yeah
i don't know it's nice to have options
yeah and okay with that in mind the
tension between the queens being a bit
too much in that variation that we just
showed black part the queen on a
different square and he's now maybe
trying to trade off the bishops on this
diagonal magnus meeting that
by attacking the black queen interesting
so he's attacking the black queen and if
we see black bloc with the bishops how
is magnus going to keep the bishops on
the board now
maybe he won't
uh i'm just trying to work out his plan
here
i think anish is still doing a very good
job here
if he can get rid of
the light square bishops um and then the
dark square bishops will probably come
off
i don't see why he should be worse i
mean he's got the open e file um he's
keeping the balance i think i think we
might be oh i was gonna say we might be
able to about see a repetition of moves
but no magnus trades things off and okay
he's lured the black queen to this
square because he wants to create a pin
on the fourth rank another example where
on pass on would be a force win if you
had to take it so yeah again if that
were just to make a move for example
pushing harry down the board very
logical as you mentioned simon pushing
this pawn forward
yeah if one person was forced of course
black doesn't have to capture this pawn
but if he did capture it as if it moved
one square then whoops the queen falls
off to the white rook and this is
actually quite a common motif in lots of
end games when to push elm pass on when
to kind of prepare it uh you often want
to trick your opponent often it looks
like this type of pawn move is just
not sensible because your opponent can
take it
but you can set it up so that your
opponent really can't take the bait uh
so interesting position uh i like what
magnus has done with this idea of a pin
on the fourth rank
anisha's queen may be feeling a bit
uncomfortable now stared down by the
white rook
i really struggled with the on pass on
raw when i was a kid actually when i
first started learning chess i was
really confused by it so i still
struggle with it yeah it's it's quite a
strange one because it's not normal that
you can capture on an empty square you
know that kind of feels like strange i
mean i think it's capturing passing is
what it's what it means but it's still a
bit strange um and it happens quite
rarely so it's hard to sort of get used
to it i think yeah yeah it's yeah
especially it's one one of the things
beginners struggle with definitely
yeah i also have to say castling also it
doesn't make that much sense either you
know the king suddenly moves two squares
and rook jumps over it like hello
why are you moving two pieces
i saw a great tweet the other day it was
uh before the tournament where someone
goes well you know chess players get
really annoyed
when uh people call rooks castles
but then we castle we castle you know
yeah what's the logic in that i did this
um pod thing with uh dom jolly who's
quite famous
and he was saying all chess players are
snobs they should just call it just call
it what they want why do they call it
why do they call it rooks why can't they
call it castles just because you're
snobs
okay we'll call it i don't mind what we
can call it so why the knight not the
horsey the horse yeah exactly yeah like
the whole british version
the porn is the prawn
[Laughter]
well
it's tower
which is sensible right yeah yeah yeah
well what is a rook is it what is the
thing it comes
persian word for i think tower i think
oh okay so i'm not quite sure so if that
does know the answer then please tweet
us using the hashtag chess champs it's
confusing because in english a rook
could also mean like a crow-like bird
which
makes no sense yeah in terms of chess at
least but uh okay meanwhile a couple of
moves the black queen we mentioned was
uncomfortable on that fourth rank so
she's gone back to reposition herself
and uh not too much else has changed so
now i'm expecting magnus to start
pushing pawns on this left flank because
he's a bit stuck otherwise
uh offering up this on pass something
it's going to remain in the position for
a long time but i don't think now
oh that's going to be interesting isn't
it still very interesting actually i
mean
this is it's a theme that's coming up
david isn't it and now yeah you could
think about it yeah maybe white could
push a pawn forward two squares in the
center hoping for on password but it's
not forced so uh
interesting moment but that would
probably help white's position if you
can move that backwards pawn uh which
we've we've noted is a weakness because
um it you know it's on that open file
and he's played it done okay so uh so it
wasn't irrelevant all the stuff we were
talking about
is in the position so black can actually
capture this pawn as if it just moved
one square and to take or not to take
that is the question it looks on
anisha's screen like he is about to go
for it there we go ompassant did happen
queen trade very quickly and white
recaptured the pawn so
still level material but black has a set
of double pawns now on the f file
black's weaknesses in front of his king
now may be hard to attack but they are
there for sure and now anish is about to
trade off the bishops was he changing
his mind again this bishop makes sense
to you then
that the piece is called a bishop it
looks like a bishop yeah uh the bishop i
think the bishop queen and king we can
understand why they're called those but
why a bishop why not like a laser beam
or like you know
arrow
i agree with you yeah you know arrow
arrow make more sense a bishop is like
clergy i think that's where it comes
from so why why why are we moving
clergymen around the world yeah and
would the bishop be a part of the war
in india sometimes well i think
before in ancient times the bishop was
an advisor to the king ah so you know
the bishop sits next to the king
okay so that makes sense that's that's
why that but uh
also the knight jumping over things
doesn't make too much logical sense of
course would you just of course would
jump over things maybe yeah but no other
piece does it yeah
yeah powers yeah send in your
suggestions on twitter you guys are very
critical of the game of chess today i
have to say
all of you making a living and being
just amazing chess players you've got to
ask
to the game you've got to ask those
questions so haven't you you know a bit
of philosophy about life you've got to
be curious right you've got to be yeah
definitely it's good to be curious yeah
so you wouldn't actually say that chess
is perfect
nothing's perfect
i kind of think the game chess is a
perfect board game
it's the perfect game if you ask me i
don't think we'd change anything if i
mean if you asked us truthfully i don't
think we would change anything because
we love it so much but uh yeah it's
interesting to think of these things and
i'd love to hear the viewers thoughts on
what we should rename the pieces
definitely what rule changes you would
suggest
yeah yeah it would be i okay i think it
would be kind of cool if the pawns would
be a little bit different so if the
pawns could have a little bit of
personality so the a pawn has a little
bit of a thing and the b pawn something
that differs from the a pawn but then
when they capture and go onto a new file
do they kind of change personalities
actually a chess variant okay where they
where they change uh value according to
what line they're on oh but i have to
say i really liked it when pontus
carlson was here and he said that in
africa
that they often teach the kids not
necessarily with pawns well they do but
they kind of don't
the value that they ascribe is in terms
of animals oh that's true so the rooks
were the rhinos how cool is that very
cool i think if you bring them to life
it's much easier for kids to learn about
them so that's that's the point if you
actually give them names one of the
points is you you make them something
and yeah kids can say oh it's it's i
recognize that pawn it's got a name so
it's sort of uh it's quite a good tool
for uh to remember stuff right so can
you imagine a world championship with a
chessa
full of animal figurines yeah i mean
yeah i'd be weird
i'm
i'm
sorry karen
i i mean i was just gonna say about the
position i mean i i think this is uh
pretty horrible for anisha i mean just
at first glance i mean just because
we're looking at the we're talking about
the pawn structure and we know that
having two pawns doubled i mean it is
nasty and and also it's a magnus
position right magnus loves playing
against small strategic uh problems
which a niche has i mean i guess it is
you know we go for a nice position for
white it's all magnus right now and also
look at the clock times magnus at 11
minutes and each down to two minutes so
a nine minute advantage for the world
champion and we know he's not feeling
well magnus carlsen but this is the type
of position this is his bread and butter
this is what he's uh specialized in
since he was young and anisha's just got
his strategy all wrong okay he pushes a
pawn forward now just stopping any kind
of rook checks maybe the white rock on
the fourth rank was about swing over but
now there is a target
for the white rook and
anish it's really hanging by a thread
for him already trades one set of rooks
but that only improves white's pawn
structure and uh yeah if black's pawns
on the f file weren't doubled if you
could put one of them back on the g file
black is completely fine but it's just
the fact that uh there are clear
weaknesses and anish has gone into his
opponent's home territory and is clearly
uncomfortable he has to use his rook to
defend his pawns now on this fifth rank
but magnus can step a pawn forward in
the center
uh just to protect his bishop it's
looks horrible flat really really bad
often
i mean i've seen openings where you give
up a pawn in order to lumber your
opponent with this terrible pawn
structure that black has on the right
side i mean it's so weak every single
one of those pawns doesn't have a friend
and uh
yeah the rook attacks it but also you
can visualize that the king could also
be an attacker there as well so you've
got harry knight mates and freddie
nightmares as well so yeah double freddy
double freddy
yeah those two f pawns would give beth
harmon nightmares and okay magnus brings
this rook across defends his bishop look
how flexible white's pawn structure is
as well white can push pretty much any
pawn if he wants to black's pawns are
all pretty much fixed that's quite a
clever move because i mean i was with
you david that you should you know push
that pawn to guard the bishop but this
way concrete yeah and the white king
might better go go where the rook was
just placed i guess is the idea um
yeah giri is just completely stuck
actually he doesn't really want to trade
bishops yet because in a pure rook game
his pawns would be even weaker um
black's rook is stuck on the fifth rank
just doing a defensive job so he has to
play with his king alone and as simon
mentioned it's very easy for white to
actually improve the king as well uh
first he's going to push pawns he's
going to try and kind of force geary to
trade off these bishops i mean magnus
he's barely thinking this is the type of
position he can just play purely on
instinct the zero calculation involved
it's just okay where do i want my pawns
where do i want my pieces and
even if you're really unwell you can
play a position like this even if you're
really tired you can play a position
like this
giri meanwhile clearly uncomfortable
with two minutes left oh wow and uh i
mean it's just
it's purely defensive he's trying to
kind of fight for the draw from move one
now in gary in this game but it's
backfired and magnus look at the
evaluation bar big advantage for him ah
okay interesting will magnus carlsen
win game two here he has a lot of time
on the clock
in the other three matches the bar
actually is very much to the middle in
all our matches
so will we have a little bit of a jewish
round it's gonna be interesting to see
so far in the tournament a lot of
decided games so that is super fun and
entertaining and minus fighting for a
win in this one yeah i'm gonna say now
i'll be shocked if magnus doesn't win
this
i know he's not feeling a hundred
percent but
just look at his last few moves he
pushed a pawn forward in the center
solidifying everything and now the white
king
kind of making its way towards those
isolated weak doubled black pawns
at his choosing he can push a pawn on
the other side to kick black's bishop
away force it to trade itself off a
white bishop
the black bishop can never run away from
that trade because white's bishop would
just go and grab a pawn
gary's just completely stuck he just has
to wait and do nothing and hope that
there's no breakthrough but the hardest
thing in chess is to do nothing right i
mean this is this is what uh is well
known when you especially when you're in
a worse position it you know it's much
more natural to try and do something you
know um so yeah i think this is another
problem that anish is going to have here
right with the clock situation i mean
the temptation the human instinct right
is to lash out at some point and
calculate your way out of danger do
something
but he can't yeah
especially if magnus is sneaky and gives
him a chance to
like break out but it was a false
promise okay so the bishops have been
traded we did speak about that you know
that there is the urge to do something
the bishops are off um which pawn should
capture the bishop
kind of look nice
look nice i would capture towards the
center
using the white b pawn to capture
inwards
maybe you think about the yeah
possibly i guess the only thing that
will make magnus pause is capturing with
the white rook offering a rook trade
but he's got to be 100 sure there that
he's winning uh so you don't go into a
king and pawn end game unless you've
calculated every single detail and maybe
it wasn't so easy for white to create a
past pawn in that endgame and suddenly
magnus looking up
is he just meditating
maybe maybe he's thinking like how do i
break this down because
there's that famous thing where you've
got to have two weaknesses and how does
white actually break through this
position i mean he doesn't have many
ways to get into black structure black
has a couple of weaknesses as you know
the double pawns the the pawn on the
half open file
but how do you actually break through
yeah and that's uh as we saw magnus
looking up now he's just recomposed
himself and you mentioned simon two
weaknesses this one is this one it's the
backwood pawn uh white's gonna attack it
soon and uh for example if black just
makes a move uh this will tie down the
black rook okay the black crook's
actually gone back already to defend
this pawn uh preempting that the other
potential weaknesses are these ones but
the black king is holding them for now
so really interesting okay magnus okay
we are actually heading towards this
position magnus he does have that
question is he going to for example
reroute his king round this way
uh to attack this pawn on the edge of
the board which is isolated is he going
to maybe maneuver his king around the
other way and then free up his rook for
example in a situation like this if
black just waits uh maybe bring his rook
back swing this rook across this way and
kind of overload the black army anish
meanwhile just has to
move back and forth yeah sitting on his
hands he's doing that but 30 seconds
maybe 10 minutes maybe there's a six
break
well you black can play e6 first yeah
yeah i i i think that's a nice waiting
move to have that in advance just in
case black also temps
was tempted to push the pawn to a6
um one idea that i had was to kind of
first of all just do some magic with
your rook just re-route it to the f line
as david showed oh i i didn't expect
to be pushed i think he had to play
otherwise white was going to play a6
yeah i wasn't expecting white to do that
i thought white might have it in reserve
yeah and now black is actually
completely stuck black's king is tied
down defending this pawn it can't move
uh black just has to move his rook back
and forth on this seventh rank it's just
gonna use these squares and wait
and okay magnus he's going the other way
around now what is his plan he's forced
black to kind of fix his pawns on these
squares but what's next for magnus
that's the big question we know that
magnus doesn't believe in fortresses but
anishigiri has tried to set up a
fortress he's hoping that white can't
break through
and okay white is just waiting anish is
just going to rotate with his rooks back
and forth as we mentioned
uh so fortress or no fortress
that is the question
i don't think it's a fortress
i think yeah i know i think white should
better break through here because
white's still got some pawn breaks i
mean uh white has these two pawns in the
center which can potentially move
especially the d pawn and
he's just maybe at the right moment
going to play this and i like the idea
he showed earlier david bringing the
white rook to the f-file hitting those
double pawns then maybe you transfer the
king the other way
still got to be one but um
it's certainly not a fortress yet also
your idea of actually breaking in the
center looks also quite dangerous as
well do them all yeah yeah just time
them well i think because and look at
the time advantage well niche is down to
40 seconds now which is uh which is
pretty uh yeah pretty bad yeah so these
are long term plans magnus has to
formulate over the next five six moves
uh but yeah it's going gonna be hard for
a niche every move magnus is gonna start
creating tiny little mini threats and
anisha is gonna have to uh burn his time
trying to counter them yeah is this a
situation as well where it's easy to
make inaccuracies that can just ruin the
whole thing for a niche maybe not this
exact moment but maybe in five or six
moves time once magnus has started to
create those threats first magnus is
just improving his king then he'll
improve his rook
and then the threats might start to come
or the pawn breaks at least as you guys
mentioned so it's looking super
dangerous for a niche geary clock
ticking down to 20 seconds in game two
against magnus carlsen
the first game was a draw okay
yeah look at what anish is doing just
king up king back king up king back it's
horrible playing that isn't it when
you're
waiting for your own doom
in some respects especially when you're
playing magnus it's like oh dear but on
the other hand there's some kind of uh
joy and the fact that you don't have to
think too much you just shuffle the kick
backwards and forwards so you don't want
to think too much you should probably be
playing drafts
oh simon your move is on the board the
breakthrough has happened is it the
right moment that's the big question and
geary clearly surprised by that because
it looks like white's giving up a pawn
and okay he's not going to take this
pawn off the board oh he is that pawn
which is too strong you couldn't let it
march forward but now this is the point
the white king has entered the game and
magnus has timed it
pretty well i think because the black
king is offside black's king is kind of
on the wrong part of the board right now
and uh oh gary look at that he clicked
on his rook looking clicked on his king
under 10 seconds he hasn't he's not sure
what to do
oh he took a passive decision as well oh
the white rook is in now the white rook
is in the black camp
and uh white can actually think about
advancing the seaport in one square
forward and i don't like that movie i
thought the black king had to come back
towards but
i think white might even offer a rook
trade if he wants yeah nice yeah wind
black's pawn in the center black is
temporarily a pawn up but look how many
weaknesses black has uh okay he does go
for this pawn uh push magnus is rushing
slightly i'm slightly concerned about
that uh for him but he's created a
passport white's a pawn now is a runner
and
okay black trying to get active with his
rook yeah i have to say magnus did rush
it because now
this is a nice move by anish because
he's getting ready to check the king on
the e4 square and then get the rook
behind the pawn and there you see he
really made a very fast move pre-move
yep so black's giving check and magnus
while rushing towards his pawn so it's
now a race it's about whether white's
pawn is quick enough to run up the board
black's rook might have to give itself
up for that but it's just about whether
the black king can start doing its own
damage magnus decided not to go and grab
pawns himself he's banking on this one
guy alice the airport uh running up the
board and magnus's king is now going to
go and support this pawn
i'm very surprised magnus is playing so
quickly because there's so much to
calculate here it's pretty much a race
any race pawn races especially it's all
about i do this you do that i do this
you do that and this type of position
you can calculate 10 moves in advance
because every moves
every move is pretty much forced but
magnus is just clearly playing by
instinct that's right and he seems to be
making the right moves the bar is liking
it he is
sick how impressive is it that he's able
to play like this i don't know it this
is bad uh strategy actually we tell our
students oh for playing like this
because he's not using when he's not
using the clock and now you can see a
pawn race i mean it might work because
anish only has a just under a minute on
the clock but is he going to bring his
rook back and challenge the black rook
yeah he is that's a nice tactic it's
going to get really complicated but yeah
okay there we go this rook offers itself
up but it's purely to distract black's
rook away from defending the white a
pawn promoting so if the white rook is
captured white will make a new queen
it's still complicated there but uh i
think a niche might have like you know
that might have been a mistake as last
movie because he doesn't really want to
lose his pawn it's such a trump i mean
you saw him put his head in his hands as
you said that finally yeah and to be
honest i i mean i think we're saying
maybe magnus is rushing but he's the
best endgame player of all time he knows
exactly what positions to aim for
and he's probably just playing a winning
plan and he realizes that that a pawn's
so strong um i don't know maybe he could
have calmed down a little bit you know
but he was only just in time magnus by
one move yeah five seconds
okay five seconds and he takes the white
rook white makes a new queen
and it's queen versus rook black's pawns
are all
a bit loose as well so no fortress in
this game it's just about whether blacks
far advanced pawn can promote later
okay he's pushing it but white can stop
that pawn with this queen or i can give
a check or two first if he wants as well
well this feels like it's winning now
for white it does doesn't matter as well
saying 4.8 advantage for magnus crosston
endgame two
and the clock is ticking so fast for a
niche geary
incredible the time difference here yeah
white can just give a check force the
black king back
so go to the g8 square okay that has had
uh has happened there and now just go
back and stop this black pawn in the
center
you want to stop it from behind that's
the best way to stop pawns there we go
and actually a couple of pawns now under
fire black's pieces aren't coordinated
if the black king was near the rook and
near this very strong pawn then maybe
black could save the game but the black
king just too far away it's hopeless now
for a niche and i think we're going to
see a result actually because
yeah yeah because pawns are going to be
dropping off in case if he gives a spike
check king will move but still the
problem persists you know there's two
pawns on priest the pawn uh on the f6
square and the far advanced pawn and now
well all he has to do is just
move his king to attack the rook and
he's done that 12 seconds no more checks
for black black has to put his rook on a
passive square the black pawn drops and
now it's just a matter of time the white
queen is going to overpower the black
rook uh she has easy roots into the
black position black's pawns are just
too weak
it's hopeless now for giri
is he about to resign in
ah i think any moment the black rook
also has no safe squares to park itself
on
okay it goes active and uh and he's
taking his earphones out he's getting
ready
to give up
one more move the queen will attack the
black pawns and that's game over
yep
it's uh looking like magnus carlsen will
take the first point in this match
against anish giri game two with the
white pieces but anish giri he keeps
playing
okay a couple of last moves here i
suppose i mean i suppose his only hope
is to get something like queen versus
brook nothing else on the board which is
still winning for white but
it's it's a bit tricky to win yeah i
think he's just going through the
motions it's the most painful thing just
to resign
um and magnus is all the time in the
world actually magnus can sit here and
wait for five minutes and let him suffer
are the players allowed to go and have a
walk maybe he could go
chill out a little bit go and get some
sushi
his legs are there yeah he's about to go
that's it that's it it's over magnus
carlsen takes the lead in the match
against anish giri